wenn ihr mäuse zu hause haben und die so
liebt oder die halt manchmal ausgebüxten
könnt ihr jetzt auch einfach wenn die
leine nehmen und damit gassi gehen etwas
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch jedes gut wir haben heute mal
wieder ein anderes szenario hört was ich
bin an meinem schreibtisch weil es wird
heute nicht ausgepackt und auch nicht
getestet heute wird reagiert aber schon
aus einem sehr bestimmten grund und zwar
ich habe vor einiger zeit schon mal das
video gemacht die lustigsten riesch
fällt also es gibt ja andauernd
irgendwelche werbungen irgendwelche
produkte ist es gar nicht immer nur ich
es gibt auch ganz viele andere verrückte
webseiten wo man sich denkt alter was
ist das bitte fünf produkt wer kauft zu
was wofür ist es gut und warum ist das
so günstig und mit diesen kriterien habe
ich bisher in online gesucht und auch
fotos von euch zugeschickt bekommen und
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal zusammen
an es wird glaube ich wirklich lustig
deswegen wünsche ganz viel spaß für mehr
partien die richtung lasten super dicken
fetten den daumen nach oben da und let's
go fangen wir mit dem ersten an das ist
das hier und zwar das ist wohl facebook
werbung oder instagram was auch immer
also hier unten drunter steht facebook
what the [ __ ] facebook ich habe wirklich
auch selbst auch schon produkte gesehen
da habe ich mich gefragt das ist doch
gar nicht legal die zu verkaufen nach
deutschland oder vielleicht auch
generell zu verkaufen hier haben wir
einfach haltet euch fest ein krug set ja
wir haben ja einmal diese diese partie
unterbrechen damit man das auch schön
fein durch die nase ziehen kann ich
glaube das war dumm dass er am anfang
vom video zu sagen weil manchmal
trackers youtube glaube ich und
vielleicht ist das video dann nicht
werbe freundlich aber wir haben für drei
dollar 1 guckt ja warum nicht schlag
doch zu was auch immer hier also dass
wir vermutlich nur mehr sein oder halt
auch gar nichts also es ist schon sehr
sehr dubios da würde ich mich wirklich
mal für interessieren was da ankommt wo
329 dollar 51 shades of graces
ja das ist absurd gestört ach guck mal
hier gibt es sogar eine instagram seite
die sich extra mit so fels befasst oder
das muss ich ja darin dass sie alles
zensieren alter wir haben hier einfach
was ist das denn
nein mein gott eine penisverlängerung
und schließlich verliert man den glauben
daran leute wenn euer kleines ja dann
könnt ihr euch einfach diese
penisverlängerungen bestellen auf euren
aufziehen und schon könnt ihr eure
freundin besser zufrieden stellen
oder halt euren partner was auch immer
da ist wenn ich das sehe das tut mir
schon irgendwie weh unten weil wie
willst du dann bis zum abschluss kommen
wenn du irgendwie gar nicht richtig da
drin bist sondern komplett ummantelt bis
von der wand ist okay wir gehen schnell
wieder weg von dieser seite
es wird immer schlimmer
ich bleibe euch nur mal hier kommt es
einmal den namen ein und dann gut das
kann man zeigen glaube ich sing day of
song und mein alter ich drehe abmahnung
ist ich muss so okay okay wir kommen zur
normalität zurück hier haben wir das
sieht auch bestanden etwas verstörend
aus wir haben ja eine peugeot der summe
wrestler sculpture 1 also einen tisch
der von einem sumo ringer getragen wird
den hätte ich auch unfassbar gerne in
meinem wohnzimmer geil alter und es ist
ja wirklich so dass die hersteller davon
dass sicherlich schön finde und denken
auch wenn das bei denen unternehmen im
wohnzimmer steht das finden die leute
bestimmt schön wenn jemand so was im
wohnzimmer hat ich würde denken der
absolut krank
kommen wir zum nächsten produkt hier
haben wir eine lässige brotbox heimsauna
das finde ich gar nicht so ausgefallen
ich muss sagen dass dingen ist unter
renten an sehr beliebt viele rentner
haben so was zu hause opas und omas und
gehen danach zusammen rein in so eine
heimsauna würde ich mir jetzt privat
nicht zulegen
warum nicht wenn man es mag hier ist
noch ein cockpit das auf 9 dollar kostet
das jetzt schon ich muss jetzt mal kurz
überprüfen ob es das wirklich gibt koks
sydney also ich kann das jetzt hier
nicht bestellen das ding ist aber was
ich mir vorstellen könnte oftmals sind
diese produkte auch nur klick bild das
man halt auf die seite geht und die gibt
es eigentlich gar nicht
ich denke mal das war dann auch jeder
okay ja ja ja ja ja eine schraubstock
ähnliche zehnagel scharf vorrichtung das
kann doch richtig auch ins auge gehen
oder wenn man da so du kannst damit
dahin zehnagel abschaben nur für zwei
dollar schon ein bisschen eklig oder er
jetzt geht es aber los wenn ihr mäuse zu
hause haben und die so liebt oder die
halt manchmal ausbüxen könnt ihr die
jetzt auch einfach wann die leine nehmen
und damit gast entschuldigung ich
korrigiere mich das sind hamster leinen
wenn man seinen hamster gassi führen
möchte kann man die sich kaufen für zwei
dollar und mit seinem hamster gassi
gehen
habt ihr schon mal jemanden gesehen der
mit seinem hamster gassi geht das wäre
mal was ich auf jeden fall noch nicht
das ist auch gut wir haben hier ein
schnarch zapfen den habe ich schon mal
getestet das problem ist also ich
schnarche selber nicht das ding
funktioniert aber wirklich also kann
halbwegs weil das seine nasenlöcher
weitet und dadurch kommt dann mehr luft
durch und dann schmeißt man nicht also
ich habe wirklich mehrere berichte zu
durchgelesen dass das funktionieren kann
es ist so krank man hier haben wir ein
einzelnes bein mit oberschenkel fällt
aus tritt öffnung
es gibt bestimmte leute die auf so was
richtig stehen das kann ich mir richtig
gut vorstellen
das ist ja ekelhaft alter was ist das
denn das ist auch kraß wir haben hier
einen ferngesteuerten fliegenden heil
also ein flugzeug was aussieht wie ein
hype
das kann man dann steuern 14 dollar
flying shark ach so ja gut das ist dann
hier so was das kann man auch als high
bestellen und dann kann man steuern also
einen luftballon gar nicht mal so
verkehrt glaube ich so für kinder ist
das doch finde ich gar nicht so schlecht
das ist doch ein gutes
geburtstagsgeschenk und hier sogar unter
wasser
ein unterwasser hey den bestelle ich du
musstest
und hier haben wir jetzt was für die
laser eine trendige kopfbedeckung wenn
die haare nass sind dann kann man ach so
da kann man seinen verein stecken und
dann werden die schneller trocken ich
kenne das von marie wenn sie keine lust
hat jetzt direkt ihre haare föhnen kommt
erst mal so ein handtuch und wenn man
das dann so löst ist es ja eigentlich
zwei fliegen mit einer klatsche alter
was ist das also ist das eine creme
gegen fuß
das würde mich eher abschrecken bei
dieser seite 1 zu kaufen muss ich sagen
um das ganze abzuschließen hätten wir
hier noch für einen dollar
eine zunge da einfach eine zunge die
aussieht wie eine zunge oder einen fisch
also so fisch könnte das auch sein oder
ich muss sagen das hat mich heute zum
großen teil
sehr schockiert manche sachen waren auch
gar nicht so schlecht und so verkehrt
aber das weiße da fragt man sich
wirklich nur wer hat sich das ausgedacht
wenn euch was so risch fans
vorgeschlagen werden könnt ihr mir die
super gerne einfach über instagram zu
schicken da heißt ich alex wie folgt mir
da gerne und wir sehen uns dann nie am
montag wieder um 19 uhr gibt's neues
video über am montag bis freitag 19 uhr
haut rein
[Musik]